now i know that i am very sexy but you
all just need to control yourselves okay
we're trying to have a conversation
hello folks i hope that you have been
having a lovely pride month and if not
i hope it gets better for you so
uh i have had a topic kind of
rattling around in my head a little bit
that i think it's time for me to address
and in some ways this is going to be an
amalgamation of
several points that i've made elsewhere
just applied in a
slightly different way i'll bring that
sort of stuff up
as it becomes relevant but you know what
honestly i've been doing this long
enough
that i think it is fair for me to
call back or reiterate points that have
been made
in older videos i think i've earned that
at this point
hopefully we'll see this isn't
actually something that i had anything
really recently make me think about
specifically it kind of happened
tangentially
so this year with pride
the question of can't get pride became a
very big
discourse item you want to see an
excellent video on it check out jesse
genders i really have nothing to add to
that specific conversation but sort of
as a subset
of that particular bit of discourse i
saw people either asking the question
is lgbtq ia plus
is that identity that life that
representation
inherently sexual and some other people
making the assertion that oh yeah it
definitely is
and i don't really want to talk about it
necessarily in the broad strokes but it
then reminded me
that one of the things that i see that
is really infuriating
when it comes to people complaining
about the representation
of queer identities in media
is the idea that it is somehow
sexualizing
things that otherwise aren't sexualized
this comes up most often
when there is queer representation in
media aimed at
kids there is a an accusation
of sexualizing children
by depicting someone of a younger age as
being
anything other than cisgender or
heterosexual
and i kind of want to engage with that
idea
and the question which again it's one of
those things where like it's not a
question usually asked in good faith but
i'll address it as if it were
which is that asking the question is
depicting queer identities
is it inherently sexualizing because
i can to a degree
understand the perspective that feels
that it
is and this is kind of the first of a
few things that i'm gonna touch on where
it references back to things i've said
before way back when i did my video
talking about the character of bill
potts
on doctor who the thing that i ended up
drilling in on a bit after
running a whole bunch of numbers on that
was talking about okay look
i can show you the data that says that
bill
did not bring up her sexuality and her
inclination towards women and her
attraction to women
any more than any straight companion
ever brought up
their attraction to men but beyond that
it still will ping a lot of people's
radar because they're not
used to it heterosexual references fade
into the background
whereas if you are not used to the
representation
of anything other than that every time
it comes up it is noteworthy it pings
your radar every time and that's kind of
a little bit
the angle by which i can understand
why people might feel
that bringing in queer identities into
pop culture media especially anything
intended to be family friendly or aimed
at kids is somehow sexualizing
because they aren't used to it enough
for the very concept to fade into the
background
instead it's very easy
honestly for cis straight people
to view queer identities through the
lens
of sexual activity actually way more
than most
of us actually view ourselves but it's
because
that's their understanding of what
that term means so when
they think or they see gay
representation
in media their understanding of what gay
means
is very much framed around
sex now it's no more framed around sex
than straight people are but straight
people are so
normalized that you can see a straight
couple and your brain will not
immediately go
to that place and to be
completely fair there is an argument to
be made
that showing young characters
expressing same-sex attractions
is sexualizing to a degree in so far
as it is displaying their
sexuality now is it sexualizing in the
sense of it's meant to make them appear
sexy to an audience it's not like no
no it's not but it is putting their
sexuality on display
but the thing is if this
is sexualizing then so
is this now this is where i'm going to
circle back around to another older
video when i did my video talking about
whether or not representation
is inherently political when i started
that project my
uh thought was that i was gonna make the
argument no it's not inherently
political what do you want about but
instead i
ended up coming out from the angle of no
representing
anyone who is underrepresented is
political but so is not representing
them
so is showing same-sex attractions
for characters whether they are in adult
media or
children targeted media is that
sexualizing
yes but so is showing a straight crush
but you don't complain about that
because you're used to it
because it's part of your normal
that's the thing we very rarely even
like
register things that we have accepted as
normal
much less think to complain about them
unless
it is a normal that is harmful to us
and i suppose to be fair the far
end of this argument is to claim that
normalizing
queer identities is harmful but i'm not
i'm not going there but there's another
side to this now up to this point
i have been using the term queer
identities which is
a umbrella term for the entire lgbtqia
plus
spectrum which would include trans
people
gender fluid people like me non-binary
two-spirit bigender agender any of those
sorts of folks
now while i am prepared to give
a little bit a little bit of
understanding and a little bit
of leeway as to why
people who are not used to seeing
representation can
look at a same-sex attraction
between two characters and feel that
that is sexualizing
i again am arguing it's not not any more
than the stuff you're not complaining
about
but i can at least understand that
perspective and go
okay i see how you got there but let's
kind of deal with that
however anyone
who claims that a gender identity
other than cisgender is
sexualizing can
go eat a bag of dicks
because nothing about one's gender
identity
is inherently sexual your sexuality is
who you are attracted
to your gender identity is who you are
now one can influence the other or at
least
what labels you use to explain what the
other is
if your identity is female and your
attractions aren't a female
that will affect what label you use
choosing the label of lesbian most
likely
but they're not actually the same thing
who i see myself as is a completely
different conversation
and a completely different experience
from who i am attracted to
in other words if you feel
that depicting trans youth is
sexualizing children
the sexualization is something you
are bringing to the table and you need
to really stop and think about that
now i am going to not really extend an
olive branch but at least glance in the
direction of one and i will say that
i suspect part of the reason other than
just
willful ignorance which is the thing but
if i'm being as generous as i can
conceivably be
i do get that a lot of people do not
properly understand the separation
between
sexuality and gender identity but you
know what um that's a you problem
and if you see a trans character
especially a young trans character
and you think that is sexualizing
possibly because your brain immediately
goes to the question that so many
people's brains go to especially these
days in
the toxic soup that is the discourse
your brain goes to what's their junk
well in a way it is sexualizing
completely within your own head
you may find yourself thinking about
what
is that person have going on below their
waist
but again that's a you problem
all that person or character is doing
is existing and if it is causing you
to think thoughts that make you
uncomfortable
you need to unpack why are you thinking
those thoughts at
all and if you think they are things you
should not be thinking about
like wondering about the downstairs
apparatus of underage characters because
you're right
you shouldn't be thinking about that
then maybe like do a little
self-searching
and wonder why your brain immediately
goes to what's in somebody's pants
when you find out there anything other
than cis
this is where the cultural education
which is way too damn slow
on everything not just on this like
let's be honest
but this is why cultural education is
important and it's why normalization is
important
because when trans
people and people with non-cisgender
identities
are viewed as not normal
then when people who see them or see
representation of them
their brain starts calculating all the
ways in which
it isn't normal and because none of this
stuff is normalized to the majority of
the population their brain is going to
go to the major differences and what's
one of the major differences well
gender identity what's one of the things
that results from that well they might
have had their junk changed ooh what was
it originally ooh what is it now like
it's a fairly natural
thought progression but it's one you
kind of need to train yourself to stop
doing
because what is going on below the belt
of any person
whether they're trans whether they're
cis whether they're a real person or
whether they're a fictional character
unless you are watching porn
it's not any of your business
and so when you claim
that representing people
like me or like any
of a bajillion other identities possible
other than cisgender
and you think inherently that's
sexualizing
no only in your head
and similarly with the depiction of
same-sex attractions is that sexualizing
a little a little no more than the stuff
that you let pass
if you think it's cute for a pre-teen
male character to be crushing on a
female character
but it's gross and sexualizing for that
exact same situation
but instead of them crushing on a female
character it's a male character crushing
out a male character
that just speaks to your biases
because the only thing that changed
about that circumstance the only thing
that changed no new depictions
exact same interactions you think one's
cute and the other's gross
then that one thing that is different is
what you think is gross
and so if you're thinking that and you
also think
i don't have bigoted thoughts towards
gay people
maybe you need to examine that a little
more closely
and it's okay if you need to do that
i've said repeatedly in the last year or
so
your gut reaction is something you
really don't have a lot of control over
i get that but
a lot of folks really really need to
examine
what those gut reactions are why they
have them
and really ask the questions
what does it say about me that this is
my gut reaction
because the very natural thing is to
assume
that whatever you feel is correct i mean
that's kind of our default that's how
most of us go through life
we operate on a base assumption that
what we
as a person think and process we come
from an assumption that we're probably
right
but if we don't challenge that if we
don't put that to the test
then we start putting a lot of weight
into gut reactions
that we haven't examined and we don't
know why we're having them
and may potentially be incredibly
harmful
when people say they think
representation is sexualizing
what they're saying is this makes me
think about sex that makes me
uncomfortable
but nothing about these depictions is
forcing you to think that
you are doing that on your own and if
your brain is going places you don't
want it to
it's not the responsibility of creators
to make you comfortable and especially
if the only thing
that is different from something that
you are comfortable with
is the existence of a queer person
that's the point where you either need
to own up
to your biases and just admit to them
or work on them and it's okay to work
i still have work to do pretty much
everybody does
that's okay but don't tell us we're the
ones sexualizing characters and
entertainment
when you're the ones who look at us and
can't stop yourself thinking about
who we bang or what we're packing
because honestly you think about it more
than we do
the notion that making a character queer
is inherently sexualizing
needed to get that off my chest hope you
found it
helpful uh thought provoking
not terrible let's go with that let's
settle for that i'll be happy
so whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it
i have a patreon which is how i pay my
bills this is my living
any amount you are able to support me
with there are rewards for every tier
including early access to videos
a patreon exclusive discord and other
perks there's also youtube memberships
if you want to go that route but
uh you don't have to the usual stuff of
like share subscribe helps me out as
well but i'm not going to give you too
much pressure on that either
because at the end of the day i want you
to remember
that you are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved you are the council
i just run the meetings and until next
time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]